thank you words to say all right hi
everybody
we're in the diner in the reception part
of the day the newest professor of
comparative Media Studies I'm kind of
being amazed right now I'm going to be
you know welcoming you I'm glad my
colleagues are here with me as our
Hendershot William Murray Kyo
heather directed our graduate program
for six years
William has run and with Henry Jenkins
built up the comparative Media Studies
program for 20 years so our reception
tonight is to both honor and thank all
of the conference attendees as well as
the founders of the CMS program here at
MIT Henry Jenkins and William R Riccio
and other faculty and students involved
in this conference such as Ian
congregant Jing Wang Jim Parrish Ethan
Zuckerman and others we also have
30-plus alums from the CMS graduate
program who are participating in the
conference this year and who have over
the years helped to build this
conference up as well as our department
so we really want to thank and recognize
all of you and you guys raise your hands
[Applause]
another personal official and building
up CMS and this conference with David
Thorburn who with Henry in the early
days I gave a speech about this last
night too so I didn't want to duplicate
everything but really important in
building up the media and transition
conference and editing the first two
volumes from MIT press which came out in
2003 so I just wanted to mention a few
things about the amazing alums and I'm
not going to do justice to all of them
because the list is exhaustive it's very
long and impressive Philip tan are you
here somewhere he's been working with us
all day he graduated in 2003 and as a
creative director of the MIT game lab
teaches game design and creative and
creating video games here at MIT Sam for
director of cultural intelligence what a
great job for Simon and mr. a CBS
company and it also co-leading various
initiatives in the future of work in
Kentucky which i think is fantastic Huma
Youssef you heard her on our plenary
today
2008 has worked with the Wilson Center
as Pakistan scholar weekly columnist for
Dawn
there probably many updates that she has
about her professional career including
being recently named one of Foreign
Policy's top 100 women on Twitter
[Applause]
Elise Graham is assistant professor of
digital humanities at the Stony Brook
University she just published last year
a book entitled the Republic of games
textual culture between all books and
new media these are people I haven't
even met yet and I hope to meet you
I'm a new participant here 2003 Sheree
slippery is now professor at Syracuse
this Newhouse School of Public
Communications and does crucial work on
media and identity construction also
raised a vital question on the session
we were just on about racial politics in
regard to digital media and democracy
which we all need to continue to work on
and think about Lilia Kilburn is now a
PhD student in anthropology at Harvard
and does great work on vocality and
sound technologies media and
communication disorders kinship and
intimacy and is also doing work in
Cameroon Josh cows to 2017 graduate is
now a data Epic's researcher at the alan
turing institute in the British Library
in London and is also PhD student at the
Oxford internet and
- I know there are a lot of people that
I have not mentioned I'm going to
mention one more and I'm sorry if I have
there's so many I said mentioning some
means I'm excluding others but we can't
go on all night
the last Mario Garcia Montez graduated
she's a Public Interest technology
capacity builder and researcher from
Mexico
she was so active at MIT and in CMS
while she was here and her main topics
of interest are privacy and information
security social exclusions in technology
and participatory processes
she's starting the ph.d program here at
MIT in the fall before I hand it off to
either of these people if they want to
say anything I want to thank our current
CMS graduate student volunteers who I
have gotten to know well over the past
three years and honored to work with
rachel thompson annie wang webby Faulk
Matt narrating Sam Mendes yaga voiture
Josefina Bushman James Wilson and a
chanc Rekha Malhotra and Sultan Sharif
Sharif all of these students have been
actively involved in this
may have greeted and registered you
presented you with a contrabass temos
and will change your life tomorrow night
with their DJ and Andrew Whitaker our
communications director staff Jessica
Tatlock and Sarah Smith many other
people that's all I'm gonna say but I
we're so happy you guys are here we
haven't had the conference for a while
we it used to be 50 to 100 people this
year we got over 300 little responses to
the call for papers and we're true in
our best to accommodate the swell of
interest in these issues these days so
thank you so much we're really honored
you're here with us tell me we're
looking forward to rich all day tomorrow
[Applause]